In this section, we will continue exploring how version control is handled in the engine
by seeing how it is managed in Unreal Engine for Fortnite, or UEFN.
Now after launching UEFN, new users will be prompted to select or create a project
from the project browser.
Within the project browser, you will need to enable Unreal Revision Control to utilize
the integrated version control tools available for your team inside UEFN.
When first creating your project, UEFN Revision Control allows users the option of selecting
a pre-existing team for each project that has been created and assigned by the project
manager in the Creator Portal.
If a pre-existing team hasn't been created for collaborative work, simply click on the
Create a Team hyperlink inside the project browser under the Project Defaults for UEFN.
This will take you directly to the Creator Portal to create or manage your team for
this project.
Here you can use the web-based Creator Portal to select your members, assign a team
name, team description, and select projects to transfer to the newly created team.
Once your project is launched, the Unreal Revision Control tools can be accessed through
the main menu in UEFN, just like they are in Unreal Engine.
Navigate up to the Tools pulldown in the main menu and move on down to the Revision
Controls section.
Version Control can also be accessed through the Revision Control Quick Access menu in
the bottom right-hand corner of any window, just like Unreal Engine.
Revision Control settings can be changed, set, or disabled by launching the Revision
Control login menu from either access option, and UEFN does support Perforce as a Revision
Control provider option if you don't want to use Unreal Revision Control.
Here, just as you would in Unreal Engine, users will populate the server, username,
and workspace where the project is located.
Be aware that Unreal Engine for Fortnite is still considered in its beta, and support
for Revision Control options will improve in future versions.
That's all for this section.
In our next section, we will take a look at Unreal GameSync.